you respect uh Sandler's game I played
with him once and the novelty of being
able to play with him and we were
guarding each other this is awesome he's
dirty he is dirty he's the type of dirty
that that you could get away with he's
the type of dirty that like if they if
the ref sees it they'll warn him from
what I've seen I've seen a bunch of
Clips he's a great facilitator
distributor of the ball like he likes to
be the point basically and like I saw
that he had a you know decent shot at
first it's like ooh Sandler I want to
impress him and then it was did you
[__] stop did you put it on him
though no I couldn't he's very strong
like his dirty would like holding a
little bit you get him off but even then
like boxing out and pushing he he knows
how to get in position well
um type of guy that when you shoot not
only does he go for the rebound as
opposed to leaving but he does it to
where he'll push me out first like I'll
shoot he'll turn around put his butt
into me I would snap on things like this
I got into a [__] melee at the Y
anybody who was like giving me a little
extra elbow